would you like to see lucky take on the
Captain America roll I mean yeah I would
love that one day absolutely I don't
know when that day will be and you know
like I just think um you know it would
be a very different Captain America I
mean you wouldn't be able to have the
same Captain America as you have him now
you know because he's a different guy
and again there's this issue where we
gotta get him to be trustworthy enough
for them to give him that you know a
responsibility I mean you know to fill
those shoes and so and those are our
shoes to fill and so you know I think I
think it's possible and I really do I
just I just think it has to be has to
make sense and we might be on infinity
hey everybody it's Charlie hopefully
you've had a chance to see black panther
by this point it's crushing it at the
box office but there was a big big
Captain America Easter Egg that we need
to talk about but I wanted to wait a
little while just because it is kind of
spoilery so if you're finding me for the
first time obviously there's so much
infinity war that's getting ready to
drop and I'm doing that Infinity
Gauntlet replica giveaway be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos I'll
explain the giveaway at the end of the
video too but most of you probably know
what's going on so I'll say careful for
spoilers for the end of black panther we
need to talk about that last post-credit
scene so I'll wait just a second okay
so they roll Winter Soldier out freshly
fixed his mind is healed he hasn't
gotten his new vibranium arm yet from
Shuri but he essentially rolls out
wearing red white and blue now he's the
white wolf as they call him so there's a
couple things going on in this moment
but I'm mostly talking about him wearing
the Captain America colors without
drawing a bunch of stars on those robes
he's almost wearing the flag the way
that Captain America
literally wore the black because most of
his costumes are patterned to look like
the American flag
so Marvel has not been very subtle with
the way that it teases things that it's
either thinking about doing in the post
it seems like hey this is something
that's coming down the road or this is
something we're thinking about doing
everyone is now wondering is Marvel
making moves like turning their giant
ship towards phase four with the idea
that Winter Soldier will eventually take
the mantle of Captain America if cap
continues to be the nomad character or
if he dies during the next two Avengers
films and the example that I point you
to towards the fact that they're really
not subtle with the things that they
tease is even during the guardians of
the galaxy to post-credits scene where
James Gunn was very open that some of
them would be traditional post-credits
scenes like hey this is just a really
cool moment with the characters and some
of them would be him doing what he would
call dumb [ __ ] like he literally said
that they had five post-credit scenes
just so that he could do some really
dumb [ __ ] and he's mostly talking about
that Inferno music video that they shot
but during that he literally put the
Grandmaster just dancing across the
credits out of context in the only way
you know what that would have meant is
if you'd read the comics or if you've
been following development on Thor
Ragnarok
[Music]
so even if they're just having a little
bit of fun they're always looking
forward like this grand master scene
might not tell you who Jeff Goldblum's
character is if you haven't read the
comics but it just gives you an idea for
some of the tone of Thor Ragnarok yes
they're doing a lot of Jack Kirby comic
book stuff but his character was pretty
silly so Yuri watch this and you're like
oh yeah that kind of gives us an idea
for what he's gonna feel like during
Ragnarok wow I didn't hear any thunder
but out of your fingers was that like
sparkles case in point
to Chris Evans potentially leaving the
role of Captain America than giving the
mantle to someone else if you look back
to Avengers age of Ultron back during
2015 before and after that movie Chris
Evans was a completely different person
and there was something really important
that happened behind the scenes at
Marvel Studios during that year you look
at Chris Evans before age of Ultron
comes out and he looks like Daniel Craig
after Skyfall if you don't know what's
going on with Daniel Craig he's just
absolutely sick of playing James Bond
like oh god I want to do anything else
he's trying to still figure out where he
belongs you know he's he's always been a
soldier he's always kind of fit in that
format he enjoys structure and enjoys
having orders and a plan and without
that he does feel a bit aimless but he
is still searching for whether or not he
can have a life outside of being Captain
America he's been of service for so long
trying to figure out what he would do
without his uniform and shield is a bit
of a puzzle so it was a pretty safe bet
at the time that Chris Evans was gonna
serve out his six picture contract which
would end with Avengers 4 and then he
would just go off and do his indie
movies he really likes to direct movies
so he was just gonna dedicate his time
to doing his own thing but then the
really important thing that happened
during that same year that age of Ultron
came out is that later that summer they
announced Marvel Studios had sort of
broken off from Marvel proper and become
its own little entity by itself at
Disney Kevin Feige and the other
producers could start treating the
actors like royalty by comparison to the
way they were treated before if you read
about any of the drama between the
Marvel CEO in Kevin Feige and all the
actors and the
movie stuff that was going on before
they broke away and it makes it sound
like from a corporate level Marvel was
trying to treat its actors more like
commodities like it didn't really care
about them as people it was gonna
lowball them on everything pinched every
dime they could possibly do literally
turn the movies into a toy factory
so after Avengers age of Ultron all the
actors started acting like they were way
happier to be at Marvel 1 because I
think they were getting paid more money
they were getting more amenities and
they were just being treated a lot nicer
what that means is is they're much more
willing to stick around and re sign
contracts but while this is all going on
exhibit 3 what's going on in the comics
so the comics now sort of follow the
movies they even change the colors of
the infinity gems with this new Marvel
fresh start to match those in the movies
but what they've been using the comics
for since the movie started blowing up
during phase 1 and phase 2 is just
testing out new ideas like they very
literally gave the shield in the title
to Falcon a couple years ago just to see
how people would react to somebody else
being Captain America in the Marvel
Universe and I think a lot of that had
to do with Marvel realizing that Chris
Evans might leave the role so it's like
we need to get people used to the idea
of someone besides Steve Rogers being
Captain America lately people have been
really upset with the stuff they've been
doing so now they're fresh start is sort
of them getting back to classic Marvel
Comics like you look at their New
Avengers here you see all the classic
Avengers front and center along with
some of the other characters that Marvel
is getting ready to introduce feature
prominently like Captain Marvel is
sitting right here even though she
hasn't been on that many versions of the
team with these other core Avengers and
then more recently in real life Chris
Evans has been doing nothing but singing
Marvel's praises you know you can't help
but try and compare it to your own life
and find kind of analogous circumstances
where you can live up to the person you
you try to portray each day know it's
been it's it's a blessing I love it
nothing they can't do men and sets and
I'm sure it's gonna have the exact same
effect when Captain Marvel comes out and
then the Black Widow movie comes out
Marvel just has the winning recipe so
given the overwhelming evidence and
Chris Evans attitudes towards Marvel
right now as we head into infinity war I
think that even though they
dropped this very big comic book Winter
Soldier becoming Captain America Easter
Egg Chris Evans will not die during the
next two Avengers films and will
continue on but the key to the way that
he continues on and is used in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is Marvel's
resident old man Tony Stark Iron Man who
I also think will stick around even
though it does feel like they need to
kill a really big a-list Avenger to make
it feel meaningful and when I'm talking
about characters dying during the next
two Avengers films I'm not talking about
characters dying during Avengers
infinity war and then being brought back
to life when reality has changed during
Avengers 4 like during Avengers 4 when
the Avengers fix all the changes that
the a nose makes they can make a couple
of minor edits so it's easier to
integrate characters like Captain Marvel
or any other new characters they want to
bring in down the line but just given
the idea that Marvel can't lose it just
feels like Captain America is gonna
stick around first say like the Black
Widow a movie and just pop up every once
in a while in other people's movies the
way that Iron Man is doing now so let me
know in the comments do you think that
Marvel is making moves just in case
Chris Evans wants to leave down the road
and they can give the mantle to someone
else but what'll happen is is obviously
there's a much more infinity war to post
I'll do a new video for what Marvel is
doing with their big pre loot story
there's a prelude to infinity war that
they have in the comics right now
there's one that directly addresses the
MCU stuff and then there's a comic book
one that sort of delves into what's
going on with the Infinity stones so
it's actually pretty cool I'll do some
videos for that in the next couple of
weeks but leave all your bonus video
requests in the comments below
and what's going on with the giveaway is
it's for one of those new Infinity
Gauntlet replicas when I announce
winners I put their names and videos but
if you've been watching my videos for a
long time you know what's up so no
worries so I'll name a new winner when I
post new Marvel click here to watch
Doctor Strange try to lift Thor's hammer
and that other yondu deleted scene and
click here for that latest infinity war
promo thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]